everyone I'm Maria natus dad and I'm a
computational biology PhD student at
Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory which is
this biology Institute out on Long
Island we have about 50 labs so about 50
professors and they all have people
under them and I'm one of those people
and today I'm gonna tell you about how
big data is transforming biology and how
we're using Python to make sense of it
all
so first I'm gonna tell you a little bit
about genome sequencing and kind of how
that's producing a lot of big data and
what we're doing to deal with that and
what are some of the things that you
might want to know about sequencing that
you may not have known before that
actually makes a big difference for
trying to do any kind of computational
work with the data then I'm gonna show
you a little bit of my own research and
how I've used Python to study cancer and
rearrange genomes and finally I'm gonna
tell you a little bit about personal
genomics to give you an idea of what
23andme does versus what genome
sequencing is and how that might apply
to you if you ever want to study your
own genome so first genome sequencing so
this is your genome if you're male
anyway and it is made up of 46 strings
that we call chromosomes and these
include DNA on the inside which is those
80 CS and G's that you may be familiar
with from school and that's the
beautiful double helix right there and
in this case it's male because there's
an X and Y chromosome so that's what
your genome looks like if you're a
female then you have two of the X
chromosomes instead of that little Y and
so why is this genome important part of
it is because if it's essentially the
instruction manual for creating you so
if anything is different between you and
another person that thing could be
completely irrelevant not do anything
different it could change your hair
color change your height something like
that or it could give you a disease like
cancer and for cancer what often happens
or what always has to happen in order to
create cancer is that you accumulate
mutations so not only are you born with
them but you might be born with one that
gives you a predisposition to when you
then accumulate more you end up with
cancer so there's both an inherited
component and a buildup of mutations and
so in this genome you have 20,000 genes
or a little bit more than that about
22,000 that are scattered all over the
genome and these are usually considered
by Sciences to be the important parts of
the genome but there's actually a lot
more to it than that so the rest of the
genome has to also be there in order to
wrap around and regulate how much output
you get from the genes and all of that
is very important so when people say
that the rest of the genome doesn't
matter they're lying
it just means that we don't know it as
well as the genes yet but let's take a
look at how we read the genome so this
is how the cost of sequencing has gone
down in the last many years the Human
Genome Project published their first
draft of the human genome in 2001 here
at the bottom at the very left most part
of the graph this is on log scale so the
cost were initially a hundred million
dollars to sequence one human genome
that's not gonna cut it for the kinds of
work that we want to do today so that
was a kind of sequencing called Sanger
sequencing was which was the original
kind that really got us very far but it
was a very expensive Human Genome
Project to do and over time this has
gone down kind of following what you
would expect from Moore's law actually
and biologists especially those of us
who do computational work in genomics we
love to show this kind of plot because
it essentially says that sequencing is
doing better than microchips and doing
better than essentially what the
computer industry is working on so in
2007 there's this technology called
Illumina sequencing which when they say
next-generation sequencing and think of
that as the cool new thing that was
Illumina sequencing which started in
2007 and ever since then this cost of
sequencing has just gone down from mad
much faster than you would expect if you
were just still following Moore's law in
fact today in this year 2015 we now have
a thousand-dollar genome so it only
takes about a thousand dollars to
sequence a human genome but if we were
still following Moore's law it would
cost more like a million dollars so I
think that's pretty good progress so I'm
not gonna tell you about the technology
behind Illumina sequencing and why it's
so much more efficient and cheaper but
what I will tell you is that having a
thousand dollar human genome has led to
a lot of data in biology being generated
not just from humans like in the
thousand genomes project and the United
Kingdom 10k genomes project but also
from genome 10k which is about
sequencing a bunch of animals across the
Tree of Life 10,000 of them and we also
have projects like the 3,000 right
genomes project which are sequencing
plants and autism genome 10k of course
is about sequencing people with autism
as well as their parents to see what
happened so these are the kinds of data
it you can actually access right now if
you wanted especially the ones from
animals because the ones from people are
sometimes protected because of privacy
considerations but if we look at what
happens when you sequence a human genome
or sequence any genome at all you
actually are trying to get at the six
billion letters that are in the human
genome
all those ATC's and G's and you just
want to read out the whole sequence but
unfortunately we can't actually do that
yet and I don't know if we will ever be
able to actually read from one end of a
chromosome to another so instead the
Illumina next-generation sequencing that
has lowered the cost so much and led to
all this sequencing now being done
actually only produces a hundred letters
of sequence at a time now this would
actually be enough and you can do the
calculations that if you sequence 100
letters at a time and you just do a
bunch of sequencing you could figure out
the entire genome as a puzzle just
overlap them until you have the whole
genome figured out
unfortunately the genome is not random
so instead of generating the genome like
this you
some people might try to model the
genome is being a random sequence where
at every new base you just roll a die
and determine what the next letter
should be unfortunately that's not
actually how it goes instead you have
something more like this we have some
pre-existing sequence and some of it
gets duplicated and gets placed
somewhere else in the genome and now
that those sequences are identical if
those are bigger than a hundred letters
long anytime you read up to that
sequence you can't see what's on the
other side and that creates a problem
because when we're trying to put
together genomes of organisms that we
don't know yet we are in fact trying to
just overlap everything and make it into
a giant puzzle and when you don't have
any reads like the ones shown up here
that actually pass all the way across
the repeat you get an ambiguity like
this one of the problems with this is
that the genome is completely full of
repeats I think it's about 50% of the
human genome is consisting of repeats
many of which are much longer than 100
base pairs so that means if you try to
assemble the genome puzzle you're gonna
get hundreds of thousands of pieces and
you don't know where any of them go so
you need other technologies in order to
put all of that together again it is
sometimes enough for the clinic if you
only want to study the genes but like we
said many things can happen outside of
the genes and the rest of the genome
that is still important but because the
technology with short reads can't quite
get there we have an issue so those are
the parts of the genome that we know the
best are the genes but what we can do is
long read DNA sequencing and so this is
developing right now and it's about 10
times as expensive as next-generation
Illumina sequencing but the read lengths
are much better so it's more like a
hundred times as long for the read
lengths the average we can get with this
instrument right now with Pacific
Biosciences is about 10,000 letters
which is not bad unfortunately is still
not enough to actually go across all the
repeats in the genome especially in
plant genomes because these have many
more repeats than our genome happens to
have and then the Oxford nanopore
midnight
is the size of a large flash drive which
is pretty exciting so you can actually
get sequencing from there but then the
throughput is actually very low so
they're still working on that and
there's some exciting things going on
here but the way that we can resolve
repeats with long reads sequencing is
that as soon as you have reads that
actually span all the way across the
repeat and anchor and unique sequence on
either side you can resolve all the
repeats and all the ambiguities from
them and get much greater contiguity
in the genome so we've actually used
long reads sequencing in a human cancer
genome as part of my own research and so
I'll show you a little bit of the
results that we've gotten from that and
first of all this is what the normal
human genome looks like again this one
is female because we have a breast
cancer sample here so it's from a woman
and this is now what the genome looks
like after cancer so this is the genome
just from the tumor mind you not her
whole body has this set of chromosomes
that still looks like the other one but
in the tumor the cells have this kind of
chromosome makeup and that's not good so
it creates a lot of issues all the genes
are going to be scattered and they're
gonna be doing very different things
than they were before and I'll show you
a little bit of that but just to orient
you this is a cell line which means that
it's been grown in the lab for many
years it was taken from a woman who was
43 years old in 1971 who had metastatic
stage 4 breast cancer that had
metastasized to her lungs
and so this was isolated from her lungs
and has been grown in the lab ever since
and probably been frozen many times too
just to keep it alive but this is the
kind of thing that scientists do to
study how human cells behave under
certain conditions because we can't
actually experiment on live humans so
that's something to be aware of so let's
talk about how we can study this kind of
genome so we're gonna sequence it just
like we normally would if we were making
up a whole new puzzle but because we
already know what a normal human genome
looks like at least
one representation of it that doesn't
encounter or encode all the variation
that is actually present in the human
population we have one representation
that's a mixture of different people but
what we can do is align the reads to it
and see where a read actually matches so
we map the reads and we see where they
go
and some reads are actually going to map
to two different places like you read up
on to a certain point and that map's
somewhere and then the rest of that read
Maps somewhere else in the genome and
that tells you that there's probably
some kind of connection between these
two chromosomes that wasn't there before
at least when you see more evidence so
we kind of count up all this evidence
and whenever we see enough evidence for
a split like this we say I think that's
one of those places in the genome where
chromosomes have gotten stuck together
wrong so that's how we actually see the
changes one of the changes that can
occur is that you have two genes that
actually get fused together in this way
because the chromosomes have actually
gotten stuck together or even within one
chromosome you can also stick the DNA
together and you get this output where
when you actually get the output of the
gene you have one gene and suddenly you
have another it's kind of like if you
were doing a recipe and you started
making a pie and then you accidentally
flip to the wrong page you kept making a
cake after that so you get an output
it's not exactly what you wanted but it
might still be functional he might still
be doing something and some of these are
actually problematic in kick sorry some
of these actually problematic in cancer
so you get some a couple of famous
examples of this like the BCR Abel gene
fusion and some gene fusions are a
little bit more complex than this you
get these complex gene fusions where
there's some gene sequence then you jump
to another sequence that not even a gene
is just somewhere else in the genome and
then you go back to a gene again and if
that sequence over there was a repeat
then you might not actually see that
connection because you can't place what
happened in between and you can still
get an output that creates a gene fusion
and
there's something in here called
splicing that I'm not gonna talk to you
about very much but it means that the
middle part actually gets cut out of the
final output so so we build an algorithm
or I build an algorithm called split
threader which is a graph library in
Python that is used to represent these
rearranged genomes because we end up in
just this cancer genome that I showed
you we have over 600 of these major
translocations major places where you
have nu adjacency a new connection in
the genome that wasn't there before and
some of those complex gene fusions can
occur that we want to be able to observe
what actually happened in the DNA to
create them and so what we can do is to
create a graph out of this genome and
what we first do is we line up all the
reads like this and we see where they
are split so here they're split at the
red line and we can count the number of
reads that are split between them kind
of as evidenced or representing how many
copies of DNA this is and then we can
count the number of reasons are still
spanning along the breakpoint
uninterrupted by that translocation so
we then make a graph where each node
represents a sequence of DNA if the
whole genome is intact then you just
have 46 different nodes one for each
chromosome and you're done but when you
have a translocation like this a novel
adjacency then you break up the nodes at
those breakpoints and you make the
connections again using edges and then
those number of reads spanning and split
become the edge weights so show you what
this looks like I guess an actual I
guess the class structure in split
threader so this is how it works we have
some nodes those are their own classes
each node has to have two ports a start
and an end port because a sequence is
not a point in space it is something
that you can read forward from one end
or backwards from the other end and both
of those are perfectly valid and
important in DNA you can read both ways
and so you
connect the nodes at those ports so the
edges are only connected to the ports
not to the nodes themselves and then you
have a graph that encompasses this whole
network its undirected right so it has
the two ports but you don't have to have
it directed because you can read either
way once a connection is made you can
read this way or that way and so that's
an important point and it's also once
you enter a node you have to go out the
other side just like if it was a tunnel
so you who if you get up to if you read
down this edge and get here you can't go
this edge you have to jump across to the
other node and go the other way as if it
was a tunnel we can talk about that
later if you're interested but think of
it as a tunnel you have to actually read
the node otherwise you haven't used it
you can't go the other way and that's
just because of the stranded nosov how
you're calling these variants and how
they're actually represented in the
genome so it's kind of a subtle point
but this is the reason why I had to make
my own graph library in order to
actually represent the sequences of DNA
other people have done this too but
they're embedded in those assemblers
that make the puzzles and so I wanted to
make one that you can actually use just
from finding the changes instead of just
reading all the sequences initially so
here are some of the things that we can
do with split thread or with having this
graph representation of the genome you
can do depth-first search of
breadth-first search I've implemented
both and you can use these to find gene
fusions like we talked about and also to
find the history of mutations that have
created a sequence in the genome so
first of all to find a gene fusion you
want to see that these two genes are
connected so you have some evidence from
RNA which let's just say that's the
output of the genes so the output of the
gene says that you have this gene fusion
so you want to find that fusion down
there and you need it to be in that
order because otherwise the output is
not functional and you can see what
order it has to be in from the output so
you want to see how it was actually
created
and you look for connections between
these two jeans and then in this case
the red connection goes through one of
the jeans in the wrong direction because
you're reading Sethe one and then you're
reading backwards into you f3h and
that's not what you want you have to
read forwards but the black connection
is going to read with one into an
intermediate notes it's a complex gene
fusion and then finally into AI f3h in
the correct direction and as long as the
intermediate sequence is small enough
that's going to yield an output from
this gene fusion that is actually a
functional output so that's how we can
look for gene fusions when we already
know what to look for and we can try to
confirm them using the graph but another
thing that we wanted to look at was when
there's too much of a gene this happens
in cancer are a lot so her2 for instance
is one of these genes that if you have
too much output from the gene that can
further the cancer and make it worse or
some of them can also start cancer in
the first place so this is what we've
normally looked like you have two copies
so you have those two strings cuz each
gene is present twice and when you
sequence you just get a very normal
baseline level and so you have a normal
breast cancer cell and everything is
fine but if there are too many copies of
the DNA we also see an increase in the
number of reads at that location when we
sequence it and finally you get too much
output of the gene which is going to
lead to too much signal for the cell to
divide we're just going to lead to too
much salt division which is what cancer
is when there's too much cell division
going on and it just keeps growing so we
wanted to look at one particular gene or
two which we see that has way too many
copies it only has two and now it
actually has 40 in the cell line and
those forty copies may be scattered all
over the genome so we're interested to
see how they became scattered how
they're became so many copies of them so
they're her2 gene up there's on
chromosome 7
this plot shows for each of those kind
of circular rectangles it is one
chromosome and so because the
chromosomes are in pairs they're only 1
up to 22 and then X because we have two
X chromosomes so the her2 gene is on
chromosome 17 you can see it has a lot
of connections down to chromosome 8 and
chromosome 8 is the most messed up of
all the chromosomes it has way too many
copies and it's gotten stuck together
with a lot of other chromosomes as well
including chromosome 17 so we were
curious to see whether there's too much
her2 because it got involved in the
messing up of chromosome 8 so when you
pile up the reads that's what's shown in
blue up here you simply see how many
reads are at each location along this
one chromosome so this is all of
chromosome 17 and if you zoom in you can
see where the reads are and you can see
where her 2 is and it's at this point
where you have a lot of reads which is
indicating too many copies of that
sequence that have gotten scattered
around the genome so this is
approximately 40 copies so when we look
at the sequence in more detail we see
that it has a lot of connections all of
which are the chromosome 8 so this is
the split reads that we're seeing here
you see how the reads are split between
the different chromosomes and there's
some interesting stuff going on here too
because we actually have a palindromic
sequence you make them by mapping the
reads so you're reading off of the
genome and when there's a split between
two chromosomes that read is going to be
split as well so half of it for instance
is going to map to one chromosome and
the other half matches another
chromosome so you can see that there's
now a connection between them in the
cancer genome because the reads are
split so you're like reading what the
chromosome now looks like and you're
mapping that read yeah you you're
reading off the genome and when you get
to that split or that break point
some of the read match is one place and
some of the read matches another place
and that wouldn't happen if you had a
completely normal genome it would just
all align perfectly in one place yes
right yeah so something that used to be
in two different places is now in one
spot and so that's what you saw with the
colored chromosomes where you have two
colors next to each other all of a
sudden that means there's a split
between the two chromosomes they're
where they've gotten connected in a way
that they weren't before so that's what
we're trying to measure here and and
that's what we're gonna encode in that
graph so using the graph we can actually
go through and so you can make a graph
out of this sequence you cut everywhere
that there is one of these novel
adjacencies and each of those sequences
now becomes a different node and you can
see how it kind of goes with the
coverage like how many reads are mapping
there everywhere that you have now a
completely different number of reads
mapping you also are seeing that there
are different notes and that shows that
our novel adjacencies are explaining the
extra copies of DNA that are there that
weren't there before so what you can do
here is to actually look through and see
what actually might have happened in
this genome to produce all those extra
copies of the her2 gene so for instance
we have a healthy chromosome 17 because
they're read spanning all the way along
there and you also see reads that are
spanning along there but are broken at
those two breakpoints the orange and the
red one and so this means that the
sequence has been copied into the other
chromosome into chromosome eight but
chromosome 17 is still completely intact
so it hasn't moved it's just been copied
and then that has now been duplicated
containing still those same breakpoints
but now also a little bit of chromosome
eight so you don't make new breakpoints
within the sequence but outside of it
and then we see some extra cuts into
this region where now another piece has
gotten copied out of that region and
into a new place and all of this is now
happening within chromosome 8 because
the 17 copy is still completely intact
and all
the ones after this all contained that
same breakpoint over on the left side
which is unlikely to happen to have
happened more than once yes because what
we see here is a baseline level of reads
going along here about 25 of them and at
these translocations you still see 25
reads that are going along the
chromosome without being split and you
see the same thing on the other side
over here and so because of that you can
infer that those are the same that it's
the same copy of DNA that's going all
along that region because it's unlikely
that it would have been cut and then
there's another sequence of it somewhere
else because we don't see that break
point in the reads that make sense okay
yeah so you compare it to a reference
genome which is basically what the human
genome project has produced and what
we've been fixing up ever since
yes exactly the reference genome should
be completely flat it should have two
copies of DNA and in this case that
would be about 25 reads all along
without any of those splits and without
any of the towers that you get from
having too many reads all right this is
good great discussion and so we also see
these complex variants going on here
that we can essentially explain using
the graph and I initially did this by
hand and just worked out how it must
have been and then I figured out how to
make split threat or do the same thing I
would do by hand but automatically
you're essentially looking for cutting
the sequence into smaller and smaller
pieces because you don't expect the same
breakpoints to occur more than once in
exactly the same location so when the
sequence is smaller it has to have come
after the orange piece was initially
excised from chromosome 17 and copied
into chromosome 8 and so you have one
more copy like that that comes out and
now you have way too many copies of her
- so you may not want to contribute to
this but this is split threader and it's
open source on github so you don't
actually have to be a biologist at all
in order to work on it but what I am
working on right now is actually to do
visualization with d3 so if you are a d3
developer you're very very welcome to
help me out I'm actually trying to
visualize that graph because right now
it's all on PowerPoint and I can print
it out a strings and so on I'm learning
d3 but it would be really cool to have
some of you on board if you know how to
do that and finally I'm gonna give you a
few words on personal genomics so so
you've not seen a little bit about
genome sequencing you've seen some of my
research which I understand is really
confusing because it's built 10 layers
on top of things like sequence alignment
that people have been working on for the
last 30 years so this is like pretty
complicated to understand I guess and so
one thing that I do want to tell you is
that let's say you do 23andme how many
of you have done 23andme nice how many
of you have heard of it ok awesome
so when I talked about sequencing before
that would be like with the Illumina
machine which is the next-generation
sequencing and that would currently cost
you about two thousand dollars to do as
a private person because it cost them
about a thousand but they'll charge you
more for analyzing it for you so if you
actually do sequencing and read your
whole genome you're getting those
hundred letter reads and that's great
for capturing most of what scientists
already know because my lab is one of
the few that are actually my lab is one
of the few that are actually working on
that long read sequencing and using that
in humans to understand things like
cancer so we can capture more of the
changes in the genome if they're
happening in repeats but since most of
the studies indices and
have been done using the short reads
that's actually totally sufficient for
understanding everything that we
currently know about what can happen to
a person because of their genetics so if
you get that kind of sequencing you're
covered as far as current science is
concerned we're not going to find
anything with long reads that is known
to be important because we haven't
studied it enough people already but if
you do something like 23andme their cost
was $100 before but I just jumped up to
200 I think because they got some new
permissions and what that's gonna do is
it uses something called a snip chip a
snip is a single nucleotide polymorphism
so that means a single one letter change
in the genome and what I was showing you
before were all these major chromosomal
fusions it's not gonna catch any of that
a womanís sequencing will capture most
of it long weed sequencing will capture
all of it but that's about $50,000 right
now so what you can get with the 23andme
chip or a snip chip from any other
company that might actually be able to
do it for you is gonna be a chip that I
think at this point it calls about a
million snips so there are a million
places in the genome where there's a one
letter change some of which we know that
it does something health-wise so there's
some evidence from some population
studies that shows that maybe this one
little change if you have it it's gonna
matter and we know what it does it might
give you a higher risk of breast cancer
or something like that and so a step
chip is gonna capture many of those
1-letter changes that we already know to
look for that we know are important but
it's not gonna capture something that we
don't know is important already of
course that's not really a big deal
because if you're only paying $200 and
you're getting nearly all of what
scientists currently know can be wrong
with a person's genetics that's really
not bad but if you're looking for some
things that are completely novel
something some of the things that we see
actually
we are some of the studies and autism
and schizophrenia there's a novel change
in a child that wasn't present in the
parents and these tend to be some of
those bigger changes that you can't find
on a snip chip because they might be
chromosomal fusions or there'll be large
deletions of a whole segment of DNA
that's just gone now so now you only
have one copy for instance and some of
these are not going to be captured with
23andme chips at all but you will get
them while sequencing and so that's just
something to be aware of when you're out
in the world and people are talking
about I want to sequence my genome with
23andme hopefully no one says that but
then you'll at least know where they're
standing with that and so I wanted to
introduce you to two of the debates that
are going on in the genomics field where
every time I go to a conference someone
is talking about these the first one is
essentially the government saying can we
actually trust people with their own
data with their results from a snip chip
like 23andme or with their sequencing
results like many companies are now
offering can we trust normal people who
don't know anything about genomics for
genetics to actually interpret their
data themselves and not overreact not
take drastic measures for their health
not knowing what a variant might
actually mean because there is some
error and all of these things we're not
always completely sure so many companies
like 23andme are gonna interpret your
health data for you and it was shut down
by the FDA for doing that because some
of those changes in the genome were not
FDA proven like the FDA had not approved
that those should be distributed to the
public you can look up your data go read
the scientific papers for that one
single nucleotide change and see what it
might be but if 23andme interpret for
you the government says people are
unlikely to understand that this is
research it's in progress and so people
might overreact and go do something
drastic ask their doctor to do something
drastic so that's one debate is can we
actually let people interpret their
health data themselves go look at the
published papers and understand what a
5% risk might mean and then this is a
really good one if you share your DNA
with the public so you put on Facebook
you get your genome sequence by Illumina
you put it on Facebook is that breaking
your brother's privacy or your kid's
privacy maybe kids who haven't even been
born yet your grandkids are you breaking
their genomic privacy because you're
sharing your DNA and they share some of
that DNA with you so that's a really
good one and I'd love to hear your
opinion on that and also if you're
interested in this kind of genomic
privacy stuff definitely watch the movie
Gattaca it blew my mind and it is
probably the best dystopian movie that
will definitely come true in the future
all right so thank you very much so does
anyone have any questions
yes definitely so there is one cancer
cell line out there that we know of that
didn't get consent and it was basically
the first one that was HeLa if you want
to know more about that you can read the
book called The Immortal Life of
Henrietta Lacks which is a book about
basically one of the very first times
that scientists were able to take cells
from the tumor and grow it in the lab
and they didn't get the woman's
permission because they were like oh my
god the cells are growing and she was
just kind of gone and they were just
like it's working it's finally working
because they've been trying to do this
for a really long time
and so they took it without her
permission kept growing the cells and
only something I think like ten years
ago was it discovered by her family that
scientists have been using her cells
this whole time but all the other cell
lines that we are using
do you have approval as far as we know
and now those HeLa cells that didn't get
approval they've actually been removed
by the family we can no longer release
any of the DNA yeah so now we don't
actually work on that anymore many
people because we can't sequence the DNA
so we can't know much about what's going
on yes
yeah that's a great question I would say
a lot of people are doing sequencing and
a lot of people are doing sequencing and
cancer but we're one of probably three
labs in the world that most who are
doing long read sequencing in cancer and
one of 10 to 15 labs who are doing long
reads sequencing at all if I were to
estimate yeah this is a very early days
kind of project yes that's a great
question yes it does
so before we sequence we have to release
many of the proteins which are what
well they do everything in your body but
they also folded DNA so we have to
release much of that so that it's naked
DNA and we can sequence it but the very
middle of the pod of the chromosome
called the centromere that's where the
chromosomes meet up before they split up
into different cells during mitosis and
meiosis so it's a really important
sequence but it's very compacted and we
actually have a lot of trouble
sequencing that at all not to mention
that it's several million letters of
just repetitive elements that we don't
really know to what extent those repeats
are important so that's kind of a work
in progress but yeah it's extremely hard
to sequence across all of that virtually
impossible any other questions any
discussion about the personal genomics
what do you think should the government
allow companies like 23andme to
interpret your health data for you and
give you a disease risk percentage based
on published scientific literature Yes
No
yes how many people say no
it um it means I think the issue is that
the FDA needs to do a lot of studies in
order to approve any given single
nucleotide change every single one of
the thousands to hundreds of thousands
that we know that might be important any
of those it has to check whether the
technology has a certain error rate it's
not that the technology isn't reliable
necessarily it's just that the FDA needs
to check that for every single single
nucleotide variant
you